joe biden gained office by promising to
return america to normalcy but his
radicalism has him shredding water at
the 100-day mark the oscars prove again
that hollywood hates you and alexander
ocasio-cortez doesn't seem all that
unhappy with kids in cages at the border
anymore
weird i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first a quick reminder we are now
spending more money than has ever been
spent by any government in human history
it is not particularly close
the government is blowing out the dollar
the effects will be felt over the next
few years
and right now they're also talking about
increasing things like the capital gains
tax so
if you are looking for a safe haven for
your money you might want to think at
least right now
now putting some money in precious
metals do you think our nation's economy
is going to be insulated from biden's
plan
massive tax increases there is a good
way to protect your savings do it over
000 other smart investors have done
convert a portion of your retirement
accounts into gold and silver
with birch gold when inflation hits and
it will gold and silver are your safe
haven and birch gold those are the
people i
trust to help you convert an ira or
eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
through april 30th on qualifying
purchases when you open a precious
metals ira with birch gold they'll send
you a free home safe birch gold those
are the people i buy my gold from you
can trust them as well text ben
to 47 4747 for your free information kit
on precious metals ira
or to speak with a birch gold
representative today with ten thousand
customers they've got an eight plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews they can
help you too
text ben to 47 47 47 for your free save
with qualifying purchase
that's ben and text ben 247 47 47
alrighty well we'll get to everything
joe biden in just a moment first
a few quick notes on the oscars so it is
perfectly clear at this point that
hollywood despises its own audience
despises it
so every so often they will make you you
know 100 million dollar movie
and that's the one that they give to you
and then there are the ones they do for
them
and the ones they do for them those are
all the ones that are featured at the
oscars
you know movies like nomad land about
elderly white people pooping in buckets
or the father
about anthony hopkins struggling with
dementia movies like
like the movie about fred hampton whose
name escapes me
at the moment about how the black
panthers were going to be the saviors of
the united states or the other movie
about how black panthers were going to
be the saviors of the united states
written by aaron sorkin
or maybe it's the borat movie which is
actually actively unfunny militantly
unfunny
but pushes all the right buttons for
folks in media land
or maybe you're just super into all of
the other movies that nobody has ever
seen that were nominated
this year it used to be that the oscars
would nominate for best picture you know
movies the people would actually see
i'm old enough to remember when the dark
knight got a best picture nomination
and when returning of the king one best
picture no movies people had actually
seen
and now hollywood only rewards movies
that no one has seen
because they actively hate their
audience they think americans are fools
they think americans are dumb asses
they think that they can basically make
money off of you by popping a marvel
movie out once in a while and then they
use that money to make the movies that
really make them feel artistic
and all of those movies of course are
critiques of the evils of america
all those movies are critiques of
america's health care system
like that the one about the the drummer
who goes deaf right which is really a
critique of america's terrible horrible
no good very bad health care system
or the or the movie about how difficult
it is to be
an asian-american immigrant in the
united states minari about the
difficulties of the american dream
right every movie is this every single
movie that was nominated this year
is essentially about the evils of the
united states in one way or another
because that's what they think of you
it's not even what they think of the
system that's what they think of their
own audience
hollywood despises its own audience and
they are living in a bubble where they
get to live off the fruit of the land
or they never have to see the
consequences of their own policies where
they get to live the high life and and
that's what the oscars represent
is how in a bubble these folks are i
mean truly insanely in a bubble how big
is that bubble
well for example according to the
post-millennial there were walls
actively erected outside the academy
awards to protect the hollywood elite
quote security fencing was erected
around the perimeter of union station in
downtown l.a on sunday to provide
protection for the hollywood elite and
their academy award ceremony the red
carpet the dazzling celebs who walked
were well secured from the general
public
union station was cordoned off with
fencing the entrances were also blocked
with security guards and additional
measures
now typically union station is you know
a station
it is like a train station in l.a so i
don't know why they couldn't hold this
thing at the kodak theater every major
venue in la
has been empty for literally a year at
this point instead they decided you know
what we're gonna displace all of these
homeless people that we welcomed
into our city to help wreck the quality
of life for people who actually pay
taxes
and live in homes and then we're gonna
make all those people move out of union
station
just like we would in malibu the
post-millennial reported union station
is typically home to a high population
of homeless yet the city of l.a forced
those city dwellers to move
from their temporary digs in order to
make room for the oscars the city moved
the homeless under the alleged threat of
destroying their belongings if they
failed to comply which is weird because
they won't do that
if a homeless person plunks down their
tent directly on the sidewalk outside of
your home the city won't move it but
if you get in the way of francis
mcdormand winning her third oscar you
are out
gang police also amply protected the
celebs who stood on stage in designer
gowns and suits to cry american law
enforcement
on teleheals and with resounding voices
actors and artists used their platform
to speak against the very institution
that was protecting them from the
greater homelessness of la
of those who spoke about the cops only
tyler perry said i refuse to hate
someone for being a police officer
so it's it's good times they've built
their own wall
apparently they uh rely on the cops to
protect them
really solid stuff there from your
hollywood brethren who who know better
than you they are just better people
than you
by the way how much better well at least
205 thousand dollars better because they
got 205 000
swag bags according to forbes.com
every year celebrity and product
placement marketing company distinctive
assets put together a gift bag the 25
nominees for best actor actress and
director
take home with them whether they win or
not every one of this year's swag bags
is valued at around 205
000 205 remember we are supposed to be
in the middle of a great depression
right now in which millions of people
were thrown out of work by a giant
pandemic
very important that the people who are
already rich and famous
are given 205 000 swag bags
that is a dip in value of 20 000 from
last year
the academy which is putting on its 93rd
oscars this year complained about the
less than wholesome nature of some of
the gifts and the negative press
surrounding it after last year this
year's gift bag reflects the twin events
overshadowing the ceremony
calls for social justice in the wake of
george floyd's murder and the outbreak
of coven 19.
distinctive assets 49 year old founder
ferry said quote
we did want the bags to feel like they
had a bigger purpose than just here's a
bag full of free stuff
some of the bags we've been doing have
been from female owned businesses black
owned businesses disabled entrepreneurs
and companies who give back
even ones you wouldn't necessarily think
give back
apparently just filled with wonderful
wonderful stuff
several of the gifts promote health and
well-being like a medical grade mask
from 99 guard
iv on call concierge vitamin intravenous
infusions to bolster immunity or to
recover from a hangover
c60 purple power antioxidant and violet
breast health supplements
but there are also some lavish things
like for example a twelve thousand
dollar four night stay for two at the
golden door a southern california spa
also you can get retreat for a three
night stay at the potter nostra
lighthouse on the island of homniskar on
the west coast of sweden
so good stuff the gift bag also includes
a 24 carat gold vape cartridges from
hollow tips and sleep capsules that
blend
cbd with low dose melatonin and hemp
cell from fifth element for post workout
recovery
really amazing stuff in this in the swag
bag these are these are folks who are
definitely
they they are a hundred percent in touch
with the american people
in touch mainly because they wish to
push you away with their hand that's the
amount of the touching that goes on it's
just
their hand on your head pushing you away
that's those are the folks in hollywood
by the way americans know it
new poll out from the daily wear today
two-thirds of americans have not seen a
single film nominated for best picture
by the way that is a lie for sure it's
more like
9 10 so people have not seen a single
film nominated for best picture if they
have seen any of the films nominated for
best picture it's probably just borat
right
because borah was on netflix so people
tuned into that for 10 minutes before
tuning out
71 of americans said award winners
shouldn't give political speeches
most americans don't think the oscars
are two white despite reporting on the
topic
55 percent of americans correctly say
that conservative films and actors would
not have a fair shot at winning an oscar
and what are the most anticipated films
for 2021
the new james bond and top gun movies
namely the ones that hollywood makes to
hate but know they have to make
in order to pay the bills for movies
that nobody ever ever wants to see
all right in just a second we're going
to get to the latest on joe biden
because again there is this disconnect
that has happened
on the left between the american people
and the left they don't understand what
their actual mandate is
people like hollywood when hollywood
does the things they want and people
like joe biden
when joe biden does the things they want
but there's a disconnect between what
joe biden wants to do and what the
american people want him to do just like
there's a disconnect between what people
want hollywood to do and what hollywood
wants to see itself doing we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about a simple fact if you're
starting a business you don't tend to
think about hr issues when we started
daily wire in a pool house we weren't
thinking about hr issues
but as your company grows you have to
start thinking about hr
if you're running a business hr issues
can absolutely hurt you wrongful
termination suits minimum
wage requirements labor regulations and
hr manager salaries aren't cheap
an average of 70 thousand bucks a year
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was created
specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy maintain your compliance all
for just 99 bucks a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat
from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day
all for just 99 bucks a month their
month to month no hidden fees you can
cancel any time
you didn't start your business because
you wanted to spend time on hr
compliance let bambi help get your free
hr
audit today go to bambi.com right now
schedule your free hr audit that is
bambi.com
shapiro spelled b-a-m-b-e-e dot com
shapiro bambi.com
shapiro and get your hr under control
for a cost that won't break the bank
today bambi.com
slash appear to get that free hr audit
okay so the disconnect
for joe biden joe biden was elected on
the basis of one promise i won't be
donald trump that was his
entire promise i may return to normalcy
stability the adults are back in charge
remember the first day
that biden went back in the white house
these were the headlines the adults are
back
these are the moderates the adults the
people who are going to restore
some semblance of non-crazy their back
there's only one problem that was a lie
joe biden has since he took office
passed a two trillion dollar unnecessary
stimulus package i say unnecessary
because
we were in the midst of the greatest
artificial depression in american
history it was caused by a single
extraneous event covered 19
which resulted in a bunch of artificial
lockdowns by state local and the federal
government
and that resulted in artificial
depression as the coveted pandemic was
relieved the economy started to boom
again
you don't need to pump up the economy in
the aftermath of already having done so
last year
in fact americans ended 2020 with the
single
greatest number in terms of wealth per
household wealth
in american history so far as i'm aware
and that's because the government
literally just sent them checks
so they had all these money in the bank
they had they were ready to go back to
work
and then joe biden blew into town and he
was like you know what two trillion
dollars boom slams it on the table and
we're going to include a bunch of new
entitlement programs we're going to
incentivize to have people uh
people to have children out of wedlock
we're going to make sure that you never
have to go back to work
right now one of the big problems for a
lot of businesses is that the government
is paying them so much
people so much to stay home that it's
hard to actually get employees to come
and work at your business you make more
money by staying home
than you would if you actually went to
work it's a serious problem in the
american economy for businesses that are
seeking to keep up
with increased demand at this point so
we're already
on the upswing joe biden blew two
trillion dollars into the economy
then he's like you know what if we spent
another two trillion dollars on
infrastructure
right and it won't mostly be
infrastructure like five percent will be
roads and bridges the rest of it will
basically be payoffs to various union
cronies
and it'll be restructuring of
unionization rules in various states in
order to incentivize unionization for
like home healthcare workers for example
two trillion dollars more now joe biden
is dropping
another two trillion dollar package so
just to keep this straight
this is all aside from the federal
budget the federal budget now every year
since obama
every year since like 2009 the federal
budget
it climbed after the 08 crash it climbed
from about 3 trillion
a year to 4 trillion a year and every
year since then
the budget of the united states has
basically been at least four trillion
dollars a year which is an insane amount
of money
it is completely unnecessary okay that's
large enough
so we're gonna spend four trillion
dollars this year then on top of that
two trillion for the boondoggle stimulus
package
which is not a stimulus package 2
trillion for infrastructure which is not
infrastructure
and now 2 trillion for quote unquote
families so now you are talking about a
grand total
of joe biden having proposed 10
trillion dollars in spending 10 right
two plus two plus two plus four
ten trillion dollars in spending for
2021 and we are three months into his
tenure
this is insanity and this is not what he
was elected to do
even some democrats are going dude i
don't know where you think we're getting
all this money from
like joe biden keeps saying oh we'll
pass tax tax increases and
in the future we'll pay for all of this
yeah no you won't we all know that
that's a lie
you just recognize that because you get
to sail in
on the height of this economic tsunami
that's about to happen
you can surf that tsunami and at the
same time you can really poison the
water
and three years from now when the
currency is inflated and when we can't
take out
any more debt because no one in their
right mind would buy an american bond
and when you have to raise taxes
dramatically in order to pay for this
syncing the economy
when all of that happens you're gonna be
long gone because joe biden ain't
running for re-election gang
joe biden wants his one-term president
look at joe biden there is no way that
man runs for re-election
honestly i will be i will be so shocked
if joe biden i mean he's on a steep path
of mental and cognitive decline it is
clear for everyone to see
this is a one-term president i mean
basically why do you think he keeps
trotting out co-president harris as
though she's an important human being
the vice presidency is a warm bucket of
spit no one cares about the vice
president except for right now
when everyone is supposed to care about
the vice president because joe biden
literally stands next to harris and
basically says
and here is the person who's going to
take over for me when i'm out
so he means to ram through all of these
world-breaking changes
in the first term and then he gets lbj
like fdr like credit even though he's
been in office for 73 minutes
right that is joe biden's plan and he is
just ratcheting this stuff up
the washington post reports today the
white house is preparing to unveil a
roughly 1.8 trillion
spending and tax plan this coming week
that includes many of biden's campaign
promises but also reflects the daunting
challenges facing the administration as
it tries to transform the us economy
question
why are we transforming the us economy
before this pandemic we had record low
unemployment
we had record high wage growth
particularly at the low end of the
economic spectrum
why why why are we remaking the most
powerful economy in world history
is there a reason for that of course not
because it's not about
helping people it's not about a stronger
economy it's about quote unquote equity
it's about getting joe biden's name in
the canton football hall of fame
as an important person the ego problems
for our presidents
typically were hemmed in by the the
checks and balances the founders
designed right they knew that
politicians were ambitious
and so they figured balance would check
that there'd be checks and balances
ambition would check ambition
and then at the beginning of the 20th
century we completely skewed the balance
between the legislature and the
executive branch
we completely destroyed the federalist
bargain between the states and the
federal government
and now basically the president acts as
a de facto king
within his own purview and then we just
change kings every four years or so
the american family's plan set to be
released ahead of the president's joint
address to congress on wednesday
calls for devoting hundreds of billions
of dollars to national child care
pre-kindergarten paid family leave and
tuition-free community college among
other domestic priorities we definitely
need more people going to useless
community colleges dr joe biden will be
unsatisfied with anything less
also we have to pay for head start even
though it's been one
more head start because it has been one
of the most ineffective government
programs in american history but let's
toss a few more billion dollars
at that and also we should definitely be
paying hundreds of billions of dollars
for national child care
specifically because that will basically
incentivize
all women to go to work and put their
kids in child care as opposed to any
women staying home
it happens to be a fact that if you want
to incentivize
women not to stay home what you do is
you create national
child care and then women are considered
better if they drop their kids at the
child kill rather than staying home with
their kids
yeah there's nothing wrong i understand
that we live in a society where we're
supposed to pretend
that there's something wrong with a
woman if she gets married and then she
spends a lot of time at home with her
kid and her husband works
that's patriarchal and evil it turns out
kids who spend a lot of time with mom
do pretty well but but we're going to
incentivize precisely the reverse
at this point obviously and incentivize
again this is the other end you have to
put it all together this is you have a
two-step
bargain that is happening right now the
the biden administration
saying that they will pay for you to
they will pay you
for having children out of wedlock that
was in the it's it's a
revision of the the welfare reform done
by bill clinton and the republicans in
the late 90s
it basically restores aid to dependent
children age of families with dependent
children
without reference to whether the parents
are married or not so you're
incentivizing single motherhood
and then you are paying for the
government to take care of the kids so
the father
the government is now playing father
again which is exactly what joe biden is
pushing for white house officials spent
much of the past week making refinements
to the plan
showing the enormous pressure they are
under to include or discard key items as
they attempt to satisfy a range of
competing voices
in a last-minute change white house
officials as of friday were planning to
include
about 200 billion dollars to extend an
increase in health insurance subsidies
through the aca exchanges so they're
going to blow out spending on obamacare
white house officials are prepared to
table a measure they'd included in
earlier drafts aimed at reducing
consumer and government spending on
prescription drugs
so they were going to um they were going
to lower the amount of spending on
prescription drugs but now they're going
to ratchet that up
again this will be the second part of
biden's buildback better agenda
following the 2.3 trillion jobs and
manufacturing proposal
okay but that doesn't take into account
the infrastructure proposal
so you're talking about six trillion
dollars of new spending six
trillion dollars of new spending
all of which is not going to make the
country stronger or better all of which
is basically designed and shoring up joe
biden's legacy
and here's the thing the american people
are not up for it they're not up for it
so there's new polling and what does it
show it shows that joe biden has not won
any additional support since the
election now you could say well joe
biden had a good level of support in the
election right i mean
he won seven million more votes than his
opponent he went about 52
of the vote but normally when presidents
enter office when they first win
especially after a very very polarizing
era they enter with these very high
approval ratings
and if they get a lot done over the
first hundred days those approval
ratings tend to rise
and this happened with barack obama he
entered office he won
he won something like 53 to 45 and
then his approval rating shot up into
the 70s at the very beginning of his
presidency
and then pretty quickly they started to
come down as people realized that what
they were promised namely a unifying
figure who was post-political and also
post-racial was lying to them
during the campaign and you saw barack
obama's numbers start to take a nosedive
so he ended up in the low 50s for most
of his presidency and that again was
largely attributable to the fact that he
was a very popular person even though
his policies weren't particularly
popular as evidenced by the fact that he
lost congress two years in
well joe biden is not nearly as
personally popular as barack obama was
he's not charming he's not charismatic
he's an old fuddy duddy
who can barely string together a
sentence and has been in washington
since
well before i was born he also happens
to have some corruption problems and
he's
again unable to coherently speak i'd say
he doesn't have any of the
personal qualities that made barack
obama very popular particularly with
independence
but he does have the same thing that
obama did which is the promise
on which he gained office has now been
discarded the promise was returned to
normalcy we're going back to normal and
then he came in he's like what if i
spend 10 trillion dollars
10 trillion dollars but if i just do
that and talk about raising the capital
gains tax
radically and talk about raising income
tax rates and talk about regulating
everything under the sun via climate
change rules
what if i do all that and the american
people are like you know what i don't
like this
i don't like this republicans heading
into 2022 have to be very optimistic
about their chances
because here's the thing it ain't going
to get better for joe biden from here
joe biden's height of popularity is when
he took office and his first few hundred
his first hundred days that's when he's
gonna get the height of his popularity
americans already got their stemi checks
so that's it for that
americans are not going to like the
costs that are associated with what joe
biden has been pushing on the country
and that's why right now again his poll
numbers are not stellar
they're quite mediocre in fact and the
media are trying to cover up for that
fact that they're quite mediocre by
saying
that he has mostly positive marks but
the question is not whether he has
mostly positive marks
the question is where is he relative to
other presidents that not name donald
trump
at this time so in just one second we're
going to get to the latest polling data
from washington post abc which shows
that joe biden is not a particularly
popular president
and this is going to have some pretty
significant downstream effects for
democrats who are running for congress
running for senate
in 2022 particularly in purple states
like georgia
okay so here are some of these poll
stats according to the washington post
52 percent of adults say they approve of
the job biden is doing compared with 42
who disapprove that's not a shock
because again he won about 52 percent of
the vote
nobody who voted for joe biden is
turning around and going oh i hate that
guy now
but he has not picked up a single
percentage point of support
from the rest and that's kind of
shocking because again
what polls tend to show people
self-reported polls particularly tend to
show that if you ask people
who they voted for after an election
they tend to say more often than they
actually voted for the person the person
who won
so normally in a normal circumstance if
you ask people how many of you voted for
joe biden in biden one
you get 60 percent of people saying they
voted for biden even though only 52 of
people
actually voted for bride well right now
his approval rating
mirrors precisely his actual voter
percentage
on the one hand you can say well that's
solid i mean it's consistent and that's
true it is solid and consistent
solid and consistent at a bare majority
which means there's a lot of room for
joe biden to slide and pretty much no
room for him to grow he now has a
ceiling his ceiling is about 52
he has no place to go but down from here
and as the effects of these
world-breaking policies are felt it's
going to go down from here
at this point in his presidency four
years ago trump's rating was 42
disapproval at 53 which again was not a
particular shock because
he only won 46 of the vote in 2016.
overall 34 of americans say they
strongly approve of biden's performance
35 say they strongly disapprove of
biden's performance
okay so he is running basically just
dead even
this by the way includes the fact that
he has huge marks for his handling of
covid
again i i struggle to see how joe biden
is going to gain from here
he's emerging from an economic
depression there's going to be a booming
economy for the next year everybody
knows that the stock market is going
bonkers
and people are going back to their
regular lives after they get vaccinated
and he's getting credit for that even
though he didn't do a damn thing about
it
i mean that's a pretty good position to
be sitting in normally in a vacuum you
say okay you got a president
with an economy that's about to boom at
like eight percent you have a
vaccine that has been tranched out at
the rate of three million a day to
americans
and people going back to work you have
people going back to their regular lives
shouldn't that president be at like 75
approval rating that ain't happening and
the reason that ain't happening is
because this dude is a partisan hack
and he is demonstrating that he is more
bernie sanders than
scoop jackson he's not an old-fashioned
moderate democrat he ain't joe manchin
he's closer to aoc than he is to a blue
dog democrat
53 of americans say they disapprove of
the way he has dealt with the
immigration
situation at the u.s mexico border which
by the way does not include aoc
right worthy of notes the people who
approve biden the most right now are
people like bernie sanders and alexander
ocasio-cortez
remember that time that alexander
ocasio-cortez got so upset with donald
trump's immigration policy and the kids
at the cages
that she actually went down to the
border in texas
and she put on a white outfit it was all
very spontaneous
she spontaneously decided to put on uh a
white outfit and then go stand outside
of an empty chain-link fence and then
stare across a parking lot
and she could maybe distantly see a
facility where there are kids being held
in cages and then stare
directly into camera and weep remember
this very spontaneous outburst of
emotion well now here's aoc spontaneous
outburst of emotion a multiple of kids
being held in cages but you know joe
biden's doing a wonderful job
almost as though the democratic party
does not give a damn about the kids in
the cages they only care about who's in
power
i do think that um
[Music]
by demonstration and president biden has
definitely
exceeded expectations that progressives
had
you know i'll be fraying i think a lot
of us expected a much more conservative
administration
um and i think that his not only what
has ultimately come out but the active
invitation and willingness and
collaboration
uh with progressives in his first
hundred days um for almost hundred days
uh has been very impressive so i i take
it no weepy photo ops at the border then
none of that interesting interesting by
the way kamala harris
who is actually put in charge of the
border situation so far
her great accomplishment has been to you
know um
well and also she has well
one thing she did was well she goes on
national tv she says things are getting
better at the border without evidence
that anything's getting better at the
border
in addition to meeting again with the
president of guatemala
i will be meeting the following day with
the community-based organizations in
guatemala they call them
basically civil society to figure out
how we can better assist what they're
doing on the ground
in a way again that they can give the
resources to people
who naturally want to stay at home and
give them some sense of hope
that help is on the way this is the work
that we're doing but it's not going to
be solved overnight it's a complex issue
listen if this were easy it would have
been handled years
ago okay okay there's only one
whenever she has to say the hard part
that's when she starts laughing like
crazy person
um so i've noticed they haven't solved
that problem and the american people
have noticed this as well 53
of americans according to again this
washington post abc news poll
say that they don't like the way that
he's dealing with the border his
approval rating for the economy stands
at 52
now normally when you have a booming
economy like you're about to get it
should be in the 70s
he's at 52 and by the way if you look at
it
by the democrat independent republican
breakdown what you notice is that he's
under water with independence
he's at 47 with independence he's at 90
with democrats which is why overall he's
at 52
but he's at 40 47 with independence
he is at 47 on the economy he's at 32
on immigration although his first
sizable initiatives enjoy majority
support the poll also finds that by two
to one
by americans say that biden should be
willing to make major changes to his
proposals to win republican support in
other words
the american people keep saying we
elected you to be a moderate and you are
not being a moderate
also 53 of americans say they are either
very or somewhat concerned that biden
will do too much to increase the size
and role of government you think
you think he's gonna spend 10 trillion
dollars that's his proposed spending
this year
okay this is again pretty these are not
great numbers for joe biden
these are these are not stellar numbers
for joe biden in fact these are the
worst numbers except for donald trump
of any modern american president at this
point in time
literally buried down in this washington
post article is the admission
that biden wins positive ratings ahead
of his 100th day better than trump
worse than every other president since
eisenhower
at this point in time obama was at 69
percent gw's at 63
bill clinton was at 59 percent hw is at
71.
reagan's at 73 carter's at 63.
the the only person who
who has a lower rating um and and it's
not net
right only only just in absolute terms
was journaled four but even he had a
plus 16 rating
biden's at plus 10 but normally
presidents are
like plus 40 plus 30 plus 20 plus 50.
if you go all the way back to like
eisenhower kennedy and johnson plus 70.
okay so this is not a popular president
by any stretch of the imagination i know
that the
media want to cram down on you the idea
that what joe biden is doing is very
popular but that's because
they are completely trying they're
trying to pretend there is no disconnect
between what joe biden wants to do and
what he was elected to do and that
disconnect is going
growing broader and broader every single
day and this is giving republicans a
real opening and if republicans cannot
ram this home
by 2022 that would be a failure on their
part a massive failure on their part
you can see that democrats are already
starting to realize what a disaster some
of this radicalism is we're gonna get to
that in just one moment first let's talk
about the fact you don't want to go to
the auto parts store because who the
hell wants to go to the auto parts store
instead
why don't you just do what you need to
do with rockauto.com
online when you go to the auto parts
store you got to stand in line you
finally get to the front of the line and
take 20 minutes explaining what part you
need the guy behind the counter then
orders the part online
and then he up charges you for it or you
could just go home and then you can just
go on rockauto.com buy the part you need
and then they'll deliver it to your
house
why wouldn't you do that especially when
you're saving a lot of money as well as
time
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
head on over to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts the rockauto.com
catalog is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
there's amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need at rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for
your car or truck right shapiro in there
how did you hear about xbox so they know
that we sent you again
that's rockauto.com right shapiro and
how did you hear about xbox
so they know that we sent you already
coming up we'll get to the radicalism
of joe biden and how even some democrats
particularly in purple states are
starting to go
i'm not sure this is going to work out
for us first if you didn't catch it
already yesterday's episode of the
sunday special features an amazing guest
dave portnoy the founder and el
presidente of barstool sports
dude is a great interview he's perfectly
honest on pretty much everything
you're going to love it he has a lot to
say about roger goodell in the state of
sports and wokeness and business
go check it out right now at
dailywire.com or on my youtube channel
ben shapiro dailywear members get access
to special bonus content from sunday
special episodes
so don't miss out join daily wire today
another high energy episode of candace
is coming at you this friday
this week canada's host political
commentator and interviewer dave rubin
they'll have a lot to discuss including
the recall election of california
governor gavin newsom and his new
opponent
caitlyn jenner that's not a joke that's
a real thing happening
in the world right now since we entered
this alternative reality
from which we cannot escape subscribe
now stream candace live on fridays 9 pm
eastern 8 pm central only on daily wire
get 25
off a new membership with code candace
at dailywire.com
subscribe make sure you grab the audio
podcast on apple spotify or wherever
your platform of choice maybe
just head on over to apple podcast or
spotify subscribe to candace today be
sure to leave a five star review if you
like what you hear you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
so here's the thing about the democratic
partisan agenda it's not popular
people don't actually like the agenda
they don't
and they're really bad effects to this
agenda democrats like to spout words
about
equity and social justice and they love
the phraseology but the actual effects
of these policies are really
really bad and so as they push radical
as they push ever more radical policies
this provides openings for republicans
to actually fight back this is what
barack obama didn't understand in 2009
he took it as a referendum on him
personally people thought his policies
were garbage and that the tea party
started
by 2010 he'd been swept out of congress
in a huge landslide
well democrats are about to experience
something similar because they don't
know what they were elected to do take
policing
okay the simple fact of the matter is
when you get rid of the cops there are
serious costs to that
particularly to the most vulnerable
story from black enterprise.com
today the area where george floyd lost
his life on may 25 2020
has become a combination of a healing
ground memorial protest location a
reminder of needed police reform
despite the presence of fresh flowers
and vibrant memorial art barricades
marked boundaries
trash must be cleaned people gather at
the place making headlines some of them
come from near and far
business owners also want others to
remember the economic justice elements
of their plate they once owned thriving
businesses now they do not now you have
to wonder yourself wait a second if this
place became like a sacred
visiting spot wouldn't that generate
some business the answer of course
is no the memorial area is located at
the intersection of east 38th street and
chicago avenue in minneapolis
tucked inside a neighborhood where
people must also live and make a living
people are still coming to the area
known as george floyd's square mainly to
pay homage to floyd
the starts were being reported that
hundreds of people trickled into the
square to hear and celebrate the chauvin
verdict earlier this week however
black-owned businesses were established
there before floyd was killed
and now they are struggling according to
the new york post report at least five
stores along one block are now shuttered
following the killing of floyd
carjackings have nearly tripled cars are
being stolen at high rates
police presence has also been reduced
that's one way to phrase it black
enterprise.com how about police presence
was reduced
therefore carjackings have nearly
tripled and cars are being stolen
at high rates black merchants said the
police have abandoned
the blocked off intersection while
creating a dangerous autonomous zone
that has seen crime spike and businesses
evaporate the new york post reported on
thursday the intersection was
essentially abandoned
save for the occasional walker who posed
for photos in front of a mural outside
cup foods the convenience store floyd
allegedly passed a counterfeit
20 bill so all the businesses in the
area are dying because it turns out that
your garbage policy has pretty garbage
consequences
doesn't matter the media and democrats
are going to push forward with their
world-breaking utopian change anyway
according to the washington post quote
after the chauvin verdict minneapolis
activists fuel up and prepare
for the long fight ahead according to
the washington post
when the chauvin trial verdict while the
chauvin trial verdict is viewed as a
victory by activists many in minneapolis
are emphasizing the conviction of one
white officer does not mean the fight is
over
nor does it erase what they see as
systemic racism in policing or other
areas of american life
justice for floyd is not final either
three other former minneapolis police
officers who were at the scene that
night are awaiting trial
on charges of aiding and abetting murder
and manslaughter in floyd's killing
prosecutors are going to try to
reinstate third degree murder charges
against each before their trial in
august so
the three guys who just were there now
those guys are gonna be charged for
three
third degree murder and it's not just
that it's amid a backdrop that many
activists said the battle for racial
equality and justice has a long
way to go and what do they want they
want to get rid of the cops
they want to they want to crack down on
the ability of police officers to do
their jobs and the media
are treating every incident now every
single incident of violence
with regard to a black suspect as an
incident of police misconduct
so for example abc world news tonight
continues to push the case of makia
bryant a case
in which a police officer saved the life
of a black girl by shooting a black girl
wielding a knife at her
they're treating that case as somehow
controversial policing here's abc world
news tonight
tonight growing cries to re-evaluate
police use of force policies in the wake
of the shooting death of ohio 16 year
old mikaya bryant
we recently had shooting after shooting
after shooting
so maybe the training is wrong
protesters hitting the streets again
today the fifth straight day since the
shooting happened
bryant's family telling me the police
need to change
they have the power right now to put
some changes in the book
just unbelievable the situation we have
to be able to do better
and protecting uh life i have a question
where was makia brian's family
throughout this entire debacle
considering she was living in a foster
home
at the time that all this happened like
where were all these family members who
actually you know take care of mickey
o'brien
when she was alive and protect her from
this situation that she was involved in
where
it's amazing how everybody's out of the
woodwork talking about how the cops are
at fault when the family members are
completely absent to the point where
this woman's
this young girl she wasn't a woman she's
16 was in a foster home
okay but in any case this is part and
parcel of a broader democratic agenda
and that agenda is to undermine policing
across the nation
karen bass democratic congresswoman from
california briefly considered as a
possible vp selection for joe biden
she said you know the cop really
shouldn't you know maybe there's a bad
case but still cops shouldn't be
shooting people
don't we need to be able to distinguish
between case yes between derek chovin
that was murder
and this which looks to me like a
righteous shooter
absolutely need to distinguish but we
also need to look at policing overall
and one of the things that i hope we
really address
is maybe the focus needs to be on
de-escalation
i know police officers are taught to
shoot to kill
a lot of people raise well why couldn't
have you shot her in a leg
why couldn't he have done all these
different things the point is we have
got to come up with the way
to stop there's so many people being
killed in this country by the way dead
giveaway that somebody doesn't know what
the
what the hell they're talking about is
when they start saying things like why
couldn't the police shoot somebody in
the leg
this is the most moronic idea that
people have ever proposed they don't
know a damn thing about guns
or police work if they think that the
officer has the ability
to like blazing saddles shoot people's
trigger fingers this is the stupidest
crap
it is a dead giveaway don't know the
hell you want that lady in charge of
your policing
it's incredible or maybe ilhan omar
should be in charge of policing because
she clearly has the best interest of
both her constituency in the country at
heart here's ilhan omar
i did not mischaracterize i think people
oftentimes read
into these statements that we make into
ways to sort of vilify us and and i
don't know
how you can't look at the the loss
of a 16 year old life as not a loss
and how you can look at a police officer
who ends up using their their weapon to
take a life
as not being a tragedy in in our
community
okay well i mean the first thing he
could do is you know point out that
perhaps the officer was justified in his
conduct considering that if he hadn't
done that there would be
another dead teenage black girl namely
the person who had been stabbed by makia
bryan if the officer hadn't done
his job maxine waters is blasting her
own critics
saying quote if we take a knee they're
mad if we speak up like i do they're mad
if we protest like mlk taught us to do
they're mad
what is it they expect us to do when
police keep killing us first of all
police haven't killed you
nor are police continuing to kill black
people willy-nilly that is a ridiculous
statement
beyond that no one cares if you speak up
like mlk we do care if you go on the
streets and then encourage people to get
violent that seems to be
more of a problem okay but but again
this is part and parcel of
a of a broader agenda which is to rip
america's institutions down
right which is presumably why jim
clyburn who's supposedly a moderate
remember jim clyburn was the guy who
pushed
joe biden in south carolina jim clyburn
is is very opposed to anti-rioting bills
so a bunch of these
states like florida texas have now
considered or passed
bills that say if you riot and you're in
public and you attack a car and the car
runs into you
you've assumed the liability it's not on
the driver which makes perfect sense
because why should you
as a driver have to sit there like a
sitting duck and maybe risk your life
that's ridiculous
okay but jim clyburn is now defending
rioters he says well you know the boston
tea party was a riot
this is about whether or not you are in
favor of maintaining
this democracy a democracy
that started off as a protest
that was called the boston tea party
that was a protest and that's what led
to what this country is today
so when people protest and you're going
to criminalize
uh the first amendment that's what
you're doing to petition
for redress of grievances that's not um
so just a little history here the boston
tea party resulted in the american
revolution which was the active
overthrow of a government
so yeah governments typically have an
interest in preventing riotous activity
directed at the active overthrow of a
government typically
that's such a bizarre thing to say that
well the boston tea party shouldn't have
been illegal because we liked that
revolution took place
but what if we actually like the
american government see the underlying
idea here is that if there's an active
overthrow of the american government
that's actually okay so long as you
believe the cause of the people who are
overthrowing the american government
that's the underlying message there if
you're comparing people
who are rioting to the boston tea party
what you're actually saying is the
american government is just as
illegitimate as the british government
was in 1775
1774 that's ridiculous it's ridiculous
on its face
okay and this this this sort of stuff
has predictable consequences kamala
harris the vice president of the
co-president of the united states she is
pushing very hard for congress to pass
the
george floyd act and this is supposed to
be directed at policing
there's only one problem with the george
floyd act which of course is that it is
massively broadly
written it is it is a bad piece of
legislation that will lead
to mass vacancy and police forces police
forces just will cease to exist as they
are currently known
i mean police officers will not sign up
for this job here's kamala harris
it was in large part because of that
case that
together with my then colleagues cory
booker in particular and then on the
house side karen bass that we wrote the
george floyd
justice and policing act and i really
do hope that the united states senate
the house has passed
it but the united states senate will
take it on and have the courage to take
it on
because there is no question that
we've got to put an end to these moments
where
the public questions whether there's
going to be accountability
okay here's the problem of course the
the george floyd act that is being
proposed is significantly broader
and significantly deeper than the police
reform bill proposed by senator tim
scott so for example
senator tim scott wanted to end
qualified immunity which means civil
cases being brought against specific
police officers
in essentially you know non-criminal
contacts
where you sue a police officer for
violation of your civil rights you're
not allowed to do that right now because
there's qualified immunity
okay but qualified immunity doesn't
extend forever right now there's there's
a couple of things you can do to curb
qualified immunity in ways that make
sense one would be
to change the current supreme court
standard which says you have to
demonstrate that the police officer
violated
a clear line right you have to
demonstrate that the police officer
violated a precedent that had already
been violated essentially okay you can
go back to what the original standard
was which was reasonable conduct
that the if the police officer a defense
was good faith and reasonableness if the
police officer did something that was
good faith or reasonable under the
circumstances he was provided qualified
immunity that was the original standard
then it was strengthened by the supreme
court so that it wasn't just good faith
and reasonableness it was you actually
had to demonstrate a case where a police
officer had done this exact thing
in the past and lost a civil suit okay
that was it that's a very high bar
you could change the standard back to
good faith and reasonableness that might
make some sense you could also
do what senator tim scott proposed and
reduce qualified immunity but not for
individual police officers instead allow
people to sue police departments
so if the police if a police officer did
something that violated the the rules
then they could sue the police
department
right that's what senator tim scott
proposed that's not what the george
floyd act does the george floyd act
basically just ends qualified immunity
period
the george floyd act basically says that
you can sue a police officer
for pretty much any reason and all you
have to demonstrate you don't have to
demonstrate
that that he acted in bad faith you
don't have to demonstrate that he act
acted unreasonably you just have to
demonstrate that he acted quote unquote
negligently or recklessly and then you
can sue him in private court
you think that anybody's going to sign
up to be a cop under these circumstances
it'll be impossible for anybody to get
insurance
nobody's gonna be a cop under these
circumstances and beyond that when they
say they want to ban chokeholds
they do understand i assume that
chokeholds are a lesser level of force
than for example a taser or a gun
when you get rid of intermediate levels
of force you're actually incentivizing
police officers to use higher levels of
force
while cops know what's coming which is
why of course nypd officers are leaving
in droves
75 percent increase in quitting our
retirements in 2020.
over 830 officers have already left the
nypd this year according to the new york
post
2 600 officers quit 2746
filed for retirement between may 25th
and june 24th of 2020 a whopping 272
officers left the force
in one month over 5 300 uniformed
officers either retired or quit in 2020.
that's crazy okay and you're about to
see more because nobody is going to
enter a police force
and there will be predictable effects of
this and when you cast the gate and
condemn
policing in this way you end up
costing wives lindsey graham is not
wrong when he says that killing
qualified immunity to the extent done by
the george floyd act not the way tim
scott was talking about
or not even curbing back qualified
immunity in the way that people like
don willett judge john willett on the
fifth circuit court of appeals or
clarence thomas has talked about when
you talk about getting rid of qualified
immunity
the way that democrats are talking about
there will be no more police officers
here here's lindsey graham explaining
qualified immunity is a very big deal if
you want to destroy policing in america
make sure that every cop can be sued
when they leave the house
so there's a way to find qualified
immunity reform
take the cop out of it my idea along
with senator scott is you can't sue the
police officer
you sue the department if there's an
allegation
of civil rights abuse or constitutional
right abuse we can solve that problem we
can solve the issues
if there's will to get there and i think
there's will to get there on part of
both parties now
okay but democrats are beginning to feel
the backlash because there will be
consequences to this this is why val
demings the democratic congresswoman
from florida who i believe wants to run
for governor here
she is now saying oh yeah the makia
bryant shooting that's probably a good
shooting
democrats are starting to realize wait a
second we are pushing too far even the
most radical democrats and vale dummies
is not a moderate
val demings came out and she's like she
used to be in the police
she says um yeah we can't do this this
way this is not going to end well
now everybody has the benefit of slowing
the video down and
and seizing the perfect moment the
officer on the street does not have that
ability he or she has to make those
split-second decisions
and they're tough but the limited
information that i know
in viewing the video it appears that the
officer responded
as he was trained to do with the main
thought
of preventing a tragedy and a
loss of life of the person who was about
to be
assaulted i mean it's just the fact that
she's saying this okay another
example democrats starting to realize
they've gone too far portland's mayor
ted wheeler
he is now asking residents to stand
together and quote unquote take the city
back
is according to the washington post
quote they want to burn they want to
bash they want to intimidate they want
to assault
he said that he will extend the state of
emergency in the city through monday
after a string of demonstrations that
have resulted in several buildings being
vandalized and public buildings to face
he said our job is to unmask them arrest
them and prosecute them
weird because for months he defended
these people but now it turns out
that even people in portland aren't
super fond of this nonsense
there will be a backlash if republicans
cannot take advantage of the fact that
democrats have completely misread their
mandate
they are incompetent they ought to be
thrown out of office frankly if they
can't take advantage of the fact that
democrats have so wildly
overreached here all right we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content in the meantime go check out
the michael knowles show where he
discusses thousands of people marching
in london to protest at vaccine
passports
you can hear more details about that
story over on michael's show that's
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
caitlyn jenner kicks off his campaign
for governor the media make a golden
idol out of fouchy an actual literal
golden idol
and elon musk laughs about how many
people will die on the first mission to
mars check it out on the michael knowles
[Music]
show